well you know you know my friends were
just kind of hanging out you know
Friday night main winds warm Allinol so
I look across the street I see my friend
Theo and they meet my friend melody both
go at the same time
yo Theo and Theo comes over and he's oh
like hey Nicky Mel what's up that's
pretty nice of him because his
girlfriend was there too and he can't
just take an order you know anyway we go
nothing much we're just kind of hanging
out you know
so the deal goes what we have a pretty
good party across town you want to like
crash so there we were at this party
we're hanging out and then we see this
guy and Jin goes it's Steven I slept
with him once I don't know if she did or
not I think she just want to get the old
jealous because he's been like ignoring
her you know so Jin goes yo Steve and it
seems like yo Jim what's up and that
just about killed Theo because he told
us about this party and there's his girl
talking to another guy
Cynthia comes over to mean he's all like
yo this just like pissing me off
I go joke I'll feel you're no winner and
it's nasty he's like oh yo you're right
so Theo goes over and starts talking to
Jen right they start to like argue and
the argument got louder and louder but I
was not listening or anything and
all of a sudden Steve screams you know
and his eyes like bug out his face turns
all purple and then she falls to the
floor somebody's knife in his back it
was horrible and I was extreme and you
know and then I had to drag me away and
sit me down then all of a sudden all
these cops come over and they were like
you've got to testify so you got me here
in your dumb courtroom and I've told you
the story as best as I could but I don't
know what happened I don't know what
Theo did